[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we are
very very very careful boys very careful
so careful we want to balance the scales
that's right and today we are going to
talk about a couple things two things
okay number one we're gonna put the last
argument that you had with your so the
[ __ ] is that your significant other oh
okay or your superior officer
authorization okay guys
superior officer
it might be the same okay it's 2003
i am not even deployed
i thought it was search optimization we
took the engine out at ceo
now it's the sexual offer oh
let's just talk about what sl could
stand for no or you remember
the last fight i had like bad ones bad
[ __ ] bad fight oh man we haven't had
a bad fan a long time you're so [ __ ]
perfect dude
no no i'm serious after we did ecstasy
like three days straight
for trying to really fix our
relationship
um we've got to understand each other
really really well that everything is
diffused in like under two minutes now
so the moral of the story is go to raves
the amount of empathy that we have that
we understand where where things are
going it's uh yeah we haven't had one
yeah when you guys are like two minutes
in because you guys will dissipate it
fast right yeah when you're two minutes
into you just pop ecstasy
what are we fighting about again oh my
god i'm so sorry i love you
i want to feel this blanket whoa this
blanket's crazy what kind of material's
a shirt oh my god you guys put the
[ __ ] lights on and [ __ ] it's oh [ __ ]
you guys do live
i've never done exercise i have a lot of
veins
i remember after uh after i got well i
didn't we didn't do ecstasy but after we
got married me and my lady did mushrooms
that was really [ __ ] cool what was on
the beach like did you guys understand
each other better no well it just
brushed you guys closer she had her own
like trip
and i just remember like she was just
kind of like staring off and she just
was like kind of happy crying a little
bit for like like two hours bro just
sitting by herself just in this the life
is just so nice and beautiful yeah she
was thinking about like you know like
the way
i think the good thing about mushrooms
from her perspective and my perspective
was it just helps you kind of look at a
certain issue that you might be thinking
about that might be on your mind just
from a different perspective and it
might kind of help
you just feel a little bit better about
it or just look at it a certain way and
just you know compartmentalize how you
feel about it you know psychedelics are
first your wife turns into a giraffe you
understand her better yeah yeah but
maybe we should try some ecstasy have
you never you might start really liking
trance
i'm out dude i'm good i'm good
i'm surprised you're a fitness dude that
doesn't listen to electronica nah dude i
don't like electronic using the hell of
joe rogan though not not in much anymore
i don't even listen to joe rogan how
much i've been listening to lex friedman
a lot i like him lexus though he's so
dope dude
i love how soft and slow he speaks
because it makes everyone else like
chill the [ __ ] out around him yeah yeah
it's pretty entertaining hearing him
he's like he's like i like to talk about
life love literature happiness
and freedom and it's like okay sure and
robotics
is that dude you already said he was
talking about the uh
the the dog from boston dynamics and he
goes when i met that the robot dogs oh
he goes i fell in love
and i was like really
when you saw that [ __ ] weird dog that
robot dog it made you like fall like
because it makes me feel scared but he
definitely sees it from a completely
different perspective obviously because
he understands it way better than i
could ever yeah he's smart we're [ __ ]
apes yeah dude and he but he's just like
yeah you know i just fell in love and i
just made me very passionate about
robots yeah we're still falling in love
with regular dogs
[Laughter]
i kind of feel them because i saw this
one um picture of a sex doll and i was
like wow
that looks human
i think i'm in love
just just starting like what was the
last time you had a fight with your
significant other i remember when i fell
in love with a sex doll
that was the last fight
ran out of batteries and stopped sucking
my dick i was like get the [ __ ] off me
what about even though
a fight you guys had i for sure had a
fight
but i don't remember what it was and it
and it just goes away so it's recent
because last week this is the i think
this is the first relationship where
fights dissipate like almost immediately
as they happen and then like it's like a
full reset button where it never even
happened that's dope is it because of uh
is it because of you guys or you think
it's because of
like the way you guys understand each
other like the dynamics because hannah
um how should i say
bends so far to my will
that i don't have to change at all as a
human being and she
changed herself completely not just
kidding what happens when you find a
[ __ ] who loves greece
the musical yeah
because that's
the musical that's what teaches them
it's literally about how you have to
change for your man
because think about what sandra did
right right she completely won it put on
the letters dude she's like i [ __ ] bad
boys now
i think it's one of those things where
um
both of us
right time right place kind of thing
where it's like we learned our mistakes
from other relationships so like and
then ultimately i don't get the feeling
of like um
they're trying to win for ego or she's
trying to win i'm trying to we're just
trying to figure out the [ __ ] problem
and then it's like what happened and
then we both
are more so aligned with how we think
individuals should be responsible for
working out their own [ __ ] not like not
like blaming the other person for the
issues that they have that's a big key
so then yeah so then it's like going
back and looking at wait where did i
[ __ ] up what did i do wrong oh i could
have done that better and then when you
hear that from the other person where
you're both parties are just like yeah
dad could have [ __ ] done that better
i [ __ ] up there yeah it makes you
go on um what do you call it you're not
so defensive it diffuses the situation
you're both now competing over no no no
that was cool no no that was cool and
then you know you know what's cool that
one time we were hanging out um and we
were talking about this when we went to
go eat the the lobster foot that didn't
have the lobster foam
[ __ ] district one
yeah
but we're
we're talking about this and we went
home me and joe were talking and we're
like and we've been together so long
that
we it feels like we've had like three or
four relationships in the same one yeah
like there's phases where we did have
the super honeymoon like year or two
right then we had the phase where we're
fighting [ __ ] every day and then
there's the other phase where it's like
we kind of and we grew as people
throughout so it's weird to like be able
to look back in one relationship and go
holy [ __ ] i think that was actually like
three or four yeah you know and then i
think about like how parents that have
stayed together for like decades i'm
like man they must be like oh [ __ ] we've
had like 10 relationships because people
keep growing and changing
and they have to grow and change
together too 100 that for me um that's
actually kind of beautiful this morning
me and nicki woke up together and she
was topless was super sick
that's always beautiful when you roll
over and you're like titties i [ __ ]
love it my ten-year-old self dreamed of
this i can't believe
i think she'll like it she loves horse
races so
so so then uh yeah we were just you know
it was like uh one of those cool things
where i was like i was cuddling her and
so she's like i love catalin and stuff
and then i was just like checking this
love you so much i was like so much i
was like and we just did the like well i
love you more than i've ever loved you
think because it really just we i feel
like we have grown together a lot and
even though we did get into an argument
like on monday because anthony was uh a
[ __ ] [ __ ] probably she's been a [ __ ]
so anthony was on our podcast last night
and i was talking about this where it
was true like it's and it sounds funny
in the moment but in the moment
because i don't i like like when she
tells me to do something i like to try
to [ __ ] nail it right and so she's
like hey can you get me like this almond
creamer for coffee you get the wrong
[ __ ] at the market
dude how long have i been doing this you
guys know me i've been doing this for
[ __ ] ever i [ __ ] it up every single
screenshot incentive or something well
that's so that's the whole thing right
it's like the perfect wrong stuff though
she's saying it's like if you she's he's
gotta go get like like non-fat ultimate
he's gonna get like sweetened vanilla
like something like it's like the
perfect opposite how is it completely
off curious how he's shocked like does
he just go
that one i told him i was like i bet
he's because he's [ __ ] in the eye
looking at that [ __ ] block
he's exactly right by the way he's
exactly right and he's like ah
that's ketchup it was that and
i was putting my coffee it was that and
i was circling this entity that i've
been watching that was finally coming to
me and price and i was like
i was like okay this is gonna be juicy
and then and then i'm there and i'm like
oh yeah i have to get wait what the [ __ ]
am i getting and i was like oh yeah i
know what i'm getting i'm getting oat
milk [ __ ] and then i [ __ ] put it i
put it
thinking
[ __ ] and i stuck the landing and like
it's like this and i'm in front of the
olympia the olympic committee and
they're all going 10 10
[ __ ]
and he's yelling at everyone in the
market he's like i got oat milk [ __ ]
you're my wife i'm like [ __ ] idiots
[ __ ] suck it [ __ ] and then i get
home and she's like oh how how
how how
how does she at least make use of that
or you have to take it back no she's
like take it back with no room in the
[ __ ] fridge because we all was
catering from new york today's video is
brought to you by curology
all right guys this is some serious
stuff we are in las vegas which means it
is very very dry and i know everyone out
there is like
you know skincare stuff that's for girls
man and i'm like
where have you been dude girls want a
guy with smooth beautiful skin so if
you're out there partying playing at the
casinos and you're here single ready to
mingle or you just want to look good for
your beautiful date that you already
have here you want to go there looking
dry like a desert boy you want to go
there look at moisturized smooth and
sexy and that's why big shout outs to
curology because i've been working with
them for the past several years they've
been sending me kids they've been
keeping this face moisturized you know
what i mean and every time i'm out here
in vegas
it's not like the desert on my face so
guys if you want ultra easy skincare
made just for you curology is the way to
go you'll get a custom prescription
cream made for you by a licensed
dermatology provider it'll be to tackle
your specific goals like acne clogged
pores dark spots wrinkles anything you
want and it's so easy you start by
taking an online quiz and if it's the
right fit they'll send your pack right
to your door so get started like we did
with curology today for a free 30-day
trial all you have to do is go to
curology c-u-r-o-l-o-g-o-y.com
off the record for a free 30-day trial
get yourself nice and moisturized all
you have to do is pay five bucks for
shipping and handling and that's it you
can take the quiz and get a custom
formula just for you that's curology.com
off the record that's curology.com off
the record to start your free 30-day
trial all you have to do is pay five
bucks for the shipping and handling you
can cancel anytime and your prescription
is subject to the consultation i'm
staying at a spot right and then
apparently uh she tells me to go get
like the mail or some [ __ ] and it's like
a new house she doesn't know what the
mailbox is right i've never seen it
before
right so he calls me that's a [ __ ]
woman's job because she doesn't have her
phone next to her because i'm talking to
her i'm just chilling with her in the
kitchen it's a big house she can't hear
from he calls me and the next thing you
know i'm the middle man in them arguing
with each other and they're yelling and
they're cussing and they're yelling and
i'm here and i'm finally i'm like this
is so wild i put on speaker now they're
cussing and yelling at each other and
i'm just there holding a phone like
watching them argue and she's like you
[ __ ] dumbass you don't [ __ ] know
the man call me [ __ ] face
dumb ass [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] i'm sitting here
like
if they [ __ ] didn't know you dude
they would think your relationship is so
tight the best it's the best well that
this is how it it's like we're flirting
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
people don't get it like that's how they
get horny it's like schoolyard type [ __ ]
yeah it's fun but and she and she
when she came up she comes out to check
the mailbox and she's like where the
[ __ ] is this dumb [ __ ]
and then i'm like where's the stupid
kind oh look i'm at the right mailbox oh
look the keynote isn't going should you
try the other game like oh yeah i think
it's completely wrong completely wrong
but he for sure nailed the right end of
t that morning at the drop yeah
so all of his right moves are being
channeled in the wrong places in the
relationship still winning somewhere
yeah it's like it's like you know you
run out of luck right so like steve uses
all his energy to be right
on crypto yeah and everything else he
[ __ ] is to his defense two things
crypto and colt stats what's called
stats thank you i mean indianapolis
i was like that was like cold stone
football in general yes but yes i love
football so yeah football and crypto
but when it comes to raiders smoking all
that [ __ ] when it comes to the grocery
store doing errands no [ __ ] bro it's all
spent yeah but i try my ass off at it
but i'm like i just get distracted and
then i don't think about it do you make
lists when you go to the supermarket i
do if it's above three i can't [ __ ]
remember anything they think now if you
give me more if you give me four things
to do i'm gonna miss at least i gotta
write it down bro i gotta write it up
you know what i think [ __ ] people up
being in relationships
when you're when i be when i was single
again
i did every [ __ ] thing by myself
that there was no like oh i could throw
this off and it'll be done okay red pill
maggie guy
i'm wearing the right [ __ ] hat of
this [ __ ] did you have to wear that for
this we don't need [ __ ] no the thing
is this though it's when you're sharing
a life
it's not about doing the thing it's
about how it's done yeah and that's the
part that you [ __ ] up what do you mean
yeah so for example like he got the oat
milk though so i'm just saying i took it
back i made it right i don't think it's
a woman's job but but go ahead
this is an imaginary imaginary scenario
that um
this is imaginary scenario because this
never happened but it'll be stuff like
this so geo likes [ __ ] fancy coffee
right because her homie center coffee so
she has a [ __ ] coffee burner thing
yeah um i like cheap ass coffee that
like [ __ ] grandmas like you just put
a spoonful of water and mix it around so
if jill's like hey can you make me some
coffee i'm like sure i'll go downstairs
and i'll make coffee and the coffee is a
morning theme for people but if i come
up it's gonna be the wrong coffee so
we're both hitting coffee we're both
cleaning the bathroom or we're both
doing the laundry
but how it's done it's not the way that
it's supposed to be done at least based
off her that's where you guys [ __ ] up
dude that's why [ __ ] are crazy though
cause [ __ ] are [ __ ] crazy you
didn't [ __ ] up what hold on let me be
wrong you know where i didn't [ __ ] up
all right
with someone outside of this country so
you guys have that exactly just like my
[ __ ] hero
you get some you gotta you get a young
girl scandinavian you get a young girl
from a porcupine
a young girl from a poor country that
you rescue their standards are extremely
low right so then like dude she's from a
little island she doesn't have anything
that we do in america right so she's
she's here from this poor little island
called wales and then um
or landon or some [ __ ] like that i don't
know but like [ __ ] they speak english
weird with the [ __ ] weird action they
speak it wrong
like so anything i give her she's like
oh my god thank you this is like this is
so wealthy
you know that's that in five years
though it might change because it's
going to because i got with the border
hopper myself
and the first two or three years they're
like oh sire this is a wonderful life
you've brought but then once they get
accustomed
then all of a sudden they think they're
equal oh my god it's when they get
citizenship
it's when they get citizenship that's
why we gotta [ __ ] keep them out yeah
but you know what i'm always like don't
talk to me like that [ __ ] you're only
half white
but you know what it's a new time it's a
new era
and i think we should be working to just
playing in the room
just playing in the room i guess
and that's why we need steve back
that's why we need steve back what's the
last time you had a fight [ __ ] a sex
however yeah
this one you know this [ __ ] was
like you know
she says that you thought i was [ __ ]
she said that i was perfect for the
first three years of feed again that's
right
yo that's some off camera [ __ ] dog
but that falls into why we think you're
such a sex hammer dude
none of us none of us got that privilege
so wag your fight's probably going to
get physically properly you probably
leak pre-cum before it's even hard too
yeah
it's just [ __ ] that's ideal by the
way that's ideal yeah i think bar i
think bart [ __ ] bad guys
like i don't think
this guy has no pre-cub precumbert's
like okay what's the best example of
[ __ ] oh dude you're basically coming
already before you even put it in
i'm so lost i don't even know how to
bring this back you know what because
most most people i'm a bio major i know
these things right yeah i do most people
their girls can't wait to talk [ __ ] to
them after the uh uh two months of being
with them okay and then you get a whole
three years yeah okay so the context is
i was secretly talking to my friends in
a van not thinking it was gonna be on
camera eventually you said this is not
for camera conversations you didn't say
that you sex happened the point is i was
talking about i was talking about how uh
nina said something to me a couple weeks
ago that was both like
the most
amazing compliment and a most wondrous
slap in the face that i've ever heard
before how's that a slap is it a slap in
the face though i think it's the how she
says it's hilarious no it's not what she
said she had her hand cocked about a
punch in her face she actually slapped
me face um but she was like you know
what when we were dating like for the
first three years i thought you were
perfect i see that's why it's hilarious
because it's like but now i know the
real [ __ ] answer
for sure but i i would give a credit to
i think uh um i was barely around right
like you guys know even with jk but you
know it's like i was traveling all the
time i was never at home for more than
like three weeks at a time so the key to
a relationship is be absent yeah don't
be around the distance make the hard
girl funny thing like it's real like we
would we would like sometimes even get
in like a mini argument and sometimes i
would even like fly across the world
thinking like i don't know where this is
going
and then like two weeks when you're by
yourself in some random obscure country
and you're just like chilling in your
hotel room and you're like done jacking
off because the internet wi-fi sucks and
you're like
i miss her damn that's d you know what i
mean and then like that distance so
every single time i felt like for the
first first couple years aka like three
years of our lives
i feel like we were constantly just
dating like just starting off so it was
almost like this like
like honeymoon phase that just kept on
pausing itself coming back and starting
fresh we would never be able to get sick
each other because by the time uh we
maybe would normally almost get to each
other it's like i already know i'm
leaving in a week so everything feels
like we should cherish our time
so we had this really really unique
thing because i was constantly gone and
then i think uh you're exercising that
healing muscle frequently yeah but but
once she like moved in with me that's
when i think she saw the real me
i'm gonna kick hannah back to [ __ ]
her
[Applause]
he's going to take her back himself have
you had a recent fight i think um it's
weird it's it's hard to understand or
pinpoint just kind of like what joe's
saying it's hard to pinpoint the exact
topics of what we're thinking nothing
stood out yet yeah but i feel like i
understand and remember the feelings of
like what we're arguing about
i think one of the complicated things is
just being in a totally different like
life space right so like for her who's
obviously brilliant super accomplished
right she just finished grad school and
got her doctorate's degree in
occupational therapy and stuff which is
amazing but for myself like i right out
of college i already started working and
failing at [ __ ] and trying different
things and building businesses and all
that stuff so just the way i see and
think and operate about things is just
just different and it's not it's not a
matter of better or worse it's literally
just different so like trying to find
that balance different phases of life
yeah you know i don't understand truly
what she's going through she doesn't
truly fully understand we just kind of
witness and respect each other and try
to empathize but yeah i think any time
you don't fully understand and you're
trying to like
you know
you don't convince each other who has a
harder oppression olympics is always a
good fight in my household the best way
to help your relationship it's the best
it's the best you always got to be the
victim because like why you know how
else you're going to win
but ultimately i think it's just trying
to
for me trying to like
respect her decision i look at her [ __ ]
i'm like you're going to school and
you're getting like two hundred thousand
dollars in debt like with your school
loans i don't [ __ ] i don't understand
that but i gotta respect it so she wants
to do yeah you're gonna pay it off so
that's fine yeah but you know it just
changes the way you think about stuff
because you're not thinking for yourself
anymore you're thinking about how how
the family is going to make it and it
just changes stuff you guys as a unit
moving forward trying to like get
through those things even if you've
never done that before or they haven't
experienced it it's just a challenging
thing you know if i was gay i would want
you to be my boyfriend same i still
think it's impressive you gave three
years of perfection yes you know that's
pretty important one and a half years i
technically wasn't around you know
three years of perfection that's why
you're such a sex average dude you
proved it you proved it what about ryan
uh the last time we had an argument yeah
was uh
it was building the studios why because
she's like i want to do it this way
the brit dude the brit that right here
she's australian
mate is that australia that's not like
brett to be dude they might
no we have to do it this way man
don't do it
is that one of those over it's uh it's
it literally is that thing you said
where it's just
how to do the thing it's like it doesn't
[ __ ] matter we're fighting about our
different methods
and it's like it's something [ __ ]
really simple like putting up a wall or
something it's just we both have a
different way in our head that it works
but we both [ __ ] don't know how to do
it but we're both
trying to figure out how to do it
separately science chicks need to tell
us how to do it i'm like just let me do
it yeah and then she's like well you do
it wrong and i'm like well i do it
there's certain jobs
and it's not that's the rule it's not
what you do it's how you do it yeah it
really is a thing of where you just have
a method in your head even if you don't
know how to [ __ ] do it like you just
have a way of logically putting the
pieces together and then they got away
too and if you don't discuss that it's
why you lost it though logic the second
you put logic in they're not speaking
the same way it's like when they want
when they want to tell you something
and i know this is a trope but it just
really is true too when the chicks want
to tell you something and they're like i
just want you to listen don't give me
your [ __ ] input you stupid piece of
[ __ ] you don't want to hear it that's us
when we're building [ __ ] it's so hard to
withhold though because i want to just
be like wow
didn't do that huh
what are you trying to help right that's
right you tried they don't want that
just listen to me i do
appreciate
the preface though
because then then i can at least try to
hold it i don't always get the breakfast
my friend preface is so important
because you got to understand when you
have to turn yourself off sometimes it's
not even about you because if they're
like i'm just going to bet that i'm like
okay cool i don't solve [ __ ] you feel
like you have to fix something
oh cool i don't have to work on myself i
just have to hear you
yeah yeah
yeah
he's slowly falling asleep
[ __ ] screensaver box i'm sorry
barton turns into a plug-in halloween
decoration uh-huh yeah yeah
this is bart he's like this and he just
goes
yeah yeah that is bart that's aboard at
7 15 tonight
we're all at his house and we're hanging
out and bart's like that's a good story
and he turns off all the lights he goes
to sleep
well people are still talking he starts
turning up pizza just gets delivered
they're talking in the dark
mark comes back downstairs hey can you
guys be quiet tiger's trying to sleep
he's like no you're trying to sleep tuck
is right here [ __ ]
i just played with his truck dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you